now there are videos coming out showing
the actual brainwashing that Isis is
doing to their children so we've got
some video from the Middle East Media
Research Institute and it appears to
show a young boy pledging allegiance to
Isis let's take a look in the in DC
within a body from her Ashley s type of
Nevada llama bet is Tesla the chef says
Clemmie bear to tell Olivia
manases hey I'm cos alpha new bed I mean
removing Arsenal Papa much of the old
Makara evil and homicide and dr. Fisk
every land and vertical love ceremony
okay alright that seems pretty scary to
me
how do we I mean this is pure
brainwashing like at the most base level
right I mean as a parent you don't know
what's going on before or after that it
is brainwashing you know I think it's
wrong what could be going on after that
but you don't you don't know you know
exactly what they're saying to that
child before and/or after you know or
what the atmosphere is look it's
absolutely wrong and it's hideous you
know but I mean I don't want you to
think I'm defending it it's it's wrong
yeah you know I think I mean I think
it's they're disgusting group I have a
problem with the indoctrination of
children into any religion you know I
think it's that you know is it there's a
relativity there that I think we can we
can debate but yeah the fact that
they're making this kid cop to you know
being willing to kill himself in the
name of the law and it's just completely
abominable so the indoctrination in at
any level because I'm sure people are
going to watch this and they're going to
say well people in the United States are
indoctrinated to believe this or that
about so but is there something a little
different about that I
think we're totally are not
indoctrinated to be killing people here
now that means that yes of course we
build all kinds of people we still have
drone strikes in Pakistan and all kinds
of horrible stuff but something seems a
little different to me is that you're
saying a little different than our
indoctrination absolutely look it's
wrong they are brainwashing but what I'm
saying is you don't know what's being
said to the kid like oh let's make a
little video like you don't know exactly
how that's coming about I have children
you don't know you can't always make a
kid go on camera and do these things or
they say what we're gonna do is this and
we're gonna put it on that you know
anybody like you and the child doesn't
understand it you know it is
brainwashing but the child really
doesn't understand when you say to a
little kid you're gonna die or get
killed
they're not really understanding that at
that age you know yeah how much of this
is just pure propaganda cuz part of me
when we've shown these things and the
headings and all that stuff like I don't
want to strength I don't want to
overplay what they really are but yet I
still think it's important that we show
some of this stuff you know Twitter took
down the video when they beheaded James
Foley a couple weeks ago they were
suspending accounts that posted the
video but to me it's like we got to sort
of show this stuff so at least we know
what we're talking about but do you
think we strengthened them sort of by by
showing this stuff and talking about it
I sort of asked you that before but now
again here I do think we strengthened
them by by people watching the James
Foley video like I had a moment where I
was like I in a [ __ ] that way I do want
to see it but I don't want to see it
because I don't want my one little
clique to even count on any kind of side
or any kind of Twitter feed you know I
don't want that to count but on the
other hand I think the woman with the
flag I mean in taking into her
menstruating on that to me that's not
strengthening their point of view at all
right the James Foley video for sure for
the record I'm pretty sure the ad rate
on a beheading video is pretty low so I
would know I wouldn't worry about your
click I know what our ad rates are
around here I just said not the ad rate
that's very funny by the way but not the
ad rate but I'm just saying I don't even
want it to count period or know that I
did that or you know even in my own
household to give them any kind of props
you know I don't even want
there yeah yeah I mean I think you bring
up a great point because it does help
perpetuate the fear which you know
they're terrorists that's what they want
they want people to be afraid of them
but I also kind of think that we need to
know who's out there especially when you
hear things you know like the hundreds
of you know America I don't know if
there are Americans or just people from
elsewhere in the world that have joined
the ISIS army yeah there's a ton of
British people now they've identified
the guy to kill James Foley and he was a
British national right so yeah there's
tons and tons of people
[Music]